we expect new guidance today on covid
booster shots and who should get them
cbs news confirms the fda intends to
announce a plan for a third shot of the
pfizer vaccine a committee recommended
last week that patients 65 and over and
those at high risk should get those
booster shots cobit 19 patients are
still crowding the icus all around the
country nancy chen is at one hospital in
kentucky that is stretched to the
absolute limit
this is not a political party or a
religion in here this isn't
this isn't about constitutional freedoms
this virus is
is an evil evil thing for dr brad baker
the fight against coronavirus is
personal he was born right here at saint
clair regional medical center and came
back for his residency right now the
virus is ravaging his home
we've been shouting from the rooftops
for a long time now
how bad this is and what this can do
and to watch it despite your your your
warnings and your your pleadings
to just come through and take life like
it does that that's hard
st claire is the largest rural hospital
in northeast kentucky and it's the only
hospital in a county of roughly 24
thousand people baker says he has open
beds but not enough nurses to staff them
you can't ask nurses to take care of any
more people than they're already taken
care of his nurses though are committed
to finding a way
nurses like cheyenne hansen who worries
what she's bringing home to her
one-year-old daughter lily she wants to
run straight to me when i walk through
the door and she can't some days it
makes me feel like a bad mom
because i'm supposed to be there for my
daughter i'm a nurse and
my patients need me
across kentucky hospitals filled with
the unvaccinated and some like 29 year
old samantha windall never make it home
misinformation kills my cousin maria
hayes is windows cousin she says wendell
thought getting vaccinated might impact
her fertility something for which there
is no scientific evidence
wendell was supposed to get married on
august 21st instead she died on
september 10th after weeks in the
hospital it was absolutely traumatizing
to have to
say goodbye to someone you love
via phone samantha was a person she we
loved her
she isn't just another number she was a
person that was well loved
for cbs mornings i'm minty chen